nous allons rentrer dans une phase
nouvelle de la gestion de la crise comme
l'a annoncé le premier ministre
mardi une première phase de
déconfinement à compter du 11 mai la
pratique sportive à reprendre mais cette
reprise ne saurait être que progressive
et prudente pour limiter les risques de
contamination
dans la même logique de concertation et
conformément aux préconisations de la
haute autorité de la santé publique jeu
proposé au premier ministre une doctrine
de reprise par étapes qui autorise dans
un premier temps uniquement la reprise
des activités individuelles extérieur
les activités devront respecter
strictement les critères de
distanciation entre les personnes ils
seront adaptés discipline par discipline
ces critères de distanciation sont dix
mètres d'écart entre les personnes pour
un footing ou qui font du vélo 4 mètres
carrés par personne et dans la limite de
100 km autour de chez soi et jusqu'au 2
juin minimum les rassemblements
autorisés sont limitées à 10 personnes
la reprise des activités en espace
intérieur et des sportifs et des sports
collectifs ne sera envisagée que dans
une seconde phase
selon l'évolution de la pandémie et la
doctrine sanitaire du gouvernement
ministère des sports est en train
d'établir une liste précise des
activités autorisées pour que chacun
puisse avoir quelque peu près son sport
favori et dans quelles conditions